the Joe Rogan experience you heard that
Instagram girl but that uh she got
banned from Instagram she was like
Instagram chick and so she got to like
help out she's decided to put out for
$10 she'll send you a naked picture in
like in like oh one week I think she's
made like seven hundred thousand dollars
for donations for the Australian fires
yeah for the Australian fires but she's
kicked off of Instagram for that no no I
think she got kicked off at Instagram
and so she's like you know what I'm just
gonna start selling pictures of me naked
then I think Instagram bird to have her
back on she's doing a lot of good yeah
they should for real she's raised that
much money to help the Australian
wildlife
yeah they deactivated her account it
says come on man you violated rules
about sexual content come on she's doing
for a good cause you [ __ ]
let her be naked
what do you stopping her from being
naked for you creeps why does Twitter
let you be naked but it's Twitter's
better yeah the naked philanthropist
she's only 20 oh poor girl doesn't know
what she's doing it I'm sending nudes to
every person who donates at least $10 to
any one of these fundraisers for
wildfires in Australia every $10 you
donate equals one nude picture from me
to your DM you must send any
confirmation that you don't need that
girl does not have a lot of hobbies
let's take a hammer she does not have
the free time damn she's hot though when
I look at that those are definitely real
she raised more than five hundred
thousand dollars wow that's amazing let
her back Instagram come on but she said
she was gonna give the money to that and
she didn't show pictures right it says
she was sending him do sex work I guess
I mean you're saying it's transient
I would imagine SRIA Lee because
Instagram wasn't getting a cut yeah
they're getting a dollar out of every
transaction may be as little it's why
snapchat has like Snap cash on how yeah
they don't have a PayPal thing and built
an instance do you think that's what
they're you that cynical
I've heard them do that for other things
that's what a lot of the ad changes were
about and why they don't let influencers
to add things anymore because they're
not getting a piece wait a minute they
don't not or like why there have been a
bunch of changes oh because they're not
getting a piece of these all those ad
sales it's going directly through the
influencer you know that's just what
I've read online hey interesting
cynicism yeah whenever I see one of
those sponsored ads one sampling here
yeah you're supposed to put that hashtag
ad after everything like weird is weird
ads are weird like dudes like holding up
a CBD bomb or the rub of their leg it's
weird you know it's like social media
the ability to make money on social
media is so new no one knows what to do
with it and it's like porn this is why
it's like porn the [ __ ] the the
people in porn always figure out first
how to push the boundaries of the
technology like technology when it comes
like streaming streaming video high
resolution video that's don't like
that's all pushed a lot of its push by
porn just the amount of bandwidth
involved in porn off the charts this is
like that don't you think they must have
figured out password-protected content
first because there's hit a bunch hidden
that's not free you know like there's a
pay version of those sites and there's a
free version but I don't know how they
figured I don't know how you thing off
those things who would go to pet you'd
be a serious pervert to say what's out
available online it's just not enough
for my tastes
I forget somebody we know very well I
feel damn it has an account yeah he's
just told me is like oh yeah I'd like to
support like oh what's marry one with
nothing wrong with that some people are
in that [ __ ]
they're like what'd you do today honey
show me your work oh you bad girl you
bad girl they took all those dicks some
guys like that you're a bad girl I'm a
bad girl daddy won't take one more dick
I'll take you for ya if Starbucks start
giving me free coffee I don't think
anybody's gonna keep paying for it what
they would think knew there was going to
help Guatemala or something don't you
think know what you think if it was like
only one kind of coffee
you know what I mean like like if you
couldn't get free iced coffees or
alcohol brews or lesbian coffee
ya know Safi let's look at only get
decaf for free oh yeah
[Applause]